mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonjour
ce dimanche c'est évidemment la journée
eddy merckx
eddy merckx qui va sans doute remporter
son deuxième tour de france
mais nous en reparlerons tout à l'heure
quand ce moment un drame se joue sur la
mer à 80 km au large des canaries
en effet cette nuit vers 2 heures du
matin le feu s'est déclaré dans la salle
des machines du paquebot italien fulvia
le feu était très violent aussitôt les
450 passagers et 200 membres d'équipage
ont été évacués et ont sauté dans
lesquelles au sauvetage
une partie de l'équipage est resté à
bord pour lutter contre l' incendie qui
serait maintenant maîtrisé aussitôt
après le sos du fulvia que vous voyez
maintenant alors qu'il partait en
croisière le paquebot france est en
service s'est dérouté pour lui porter
secours
je vous propose maintenant d'écouter une
bande enregistrée ce matin par nos
camarades de france inter qui sont
entrés en liaison avec les serviles 5 à
6 heures mais c'est à dire que vous
voyez les canots de sauvetage qui ont
été descendus du paquebot vous pensez
les recueillir dans combien de temps à
peu près quelle est la situation du
bateau fut il vient il est en flammes
actuellement encore oui est-ce que vous
avez connaissance de perte ou de blessés
à bord
respectueux helmand lincendie du
paquebot continue aux dernières
nouvelles le feu n'aurait fait aucune
victime et le paquebot france est en
servile procède maintenant au sauvetage
des passagers qui sont dans les cas nous
revenons donc à eddy merckx sera
aujourd'hui son triomphe dans le tour de
france et vous serez sans doute nombreux
à regarder son arrivée au vélodrome
municipal de la cipale cet après midi
mais je vous propose de regarder une
nouvelle fois encore cette
extraordinaire champion qui a dominé le
tour de france de la tête des épaules et
bien sûr des jambes c'est à 13h45 que
partira le premier coureur de la
dernière étape
eddy merckx partira à 15h41
il porte le numéro 1 car il a gagné
l'année dernière il le portera l'année
prochaine s'il décide de faire un
troisième tour de france cette image de
marque
remontant le peloton résume la
domination du belge durant toute
l'épreuve
quelle que soit la valeur de chacun
merde double tous ses adversaires il ne
lui reste plus qu'à triompher avec
panache ce qu'il fait volontiers sport
encore dernière journée des championnats
de france d'athlétisme avec n'allait sur
400 m et peut être un exploit au poids
puisque hier en qualifications brouzes
et a réussi un jet de 19 m 67 à trois
centimètres du record de france de colza
les pompiers les sauveteurs qui depuis
six jours on luttait contre les
incendies dans la région méditerranéenne
vont peut être pouvoir enfin se reposer
en effet ce matin tous les foyers sont
maîtrisés à part la région de vidauban
où le feu couve encore 15 à 20 mille
hectares de pinède et de garrigue ravagé
un mort une dizaine de blessés 100
millions de dégâts le bilan est très
lourd
les enquêtes continuent pour connaître
les origines des sinistres à fréjus hier
on arrêtait clément girard 39 ans qui
avait mis le feu dans trois dépôts de la
ville un jeune agriculteur monsieur
pinto a été arrêté il aurait mis le feu
dans deux endroits
mais la grande affaire reste le cas
ernest beaux lots est il innocent est il
coupable
son avocat maître moutet juge dossier
bien mince et a demandé sa liberté
provisoire
françois cornet a rencontré hier m
moutet je veux dire que connaissant
boulot je croyais difficilement
sa culpabilité aux faits qui lui étaient
reprochés je réservais cependant mon
jugement
j'ai cet après-midi consulter le dossier
de l'information
après l'avoir consulté je suis plus que
jamais persuadé de l'innocence totale de
monsieur vau l'eau et c'est ce qui m'a
amené dès à présent a déposé ce soir une
demande de mise en liberté provisoire
après avoir consulté le dossier m pensez
vous que la déposition des témoins sera
déterminante
je pense en ce qui concerne les témoins
qu'ils ont certaines ont fait des
dépositions sous le coup de l'émotion
qu'il pouvait ressentir peut être aussi
d'une certaine psychose ou panique ou
psychose qui avaient pu s'emparer des
gens au moment des faits on a parlé de
l'origine possiblement criminel de
certains de ces incendies je suis
convaincu que c'est un élément qui a pu
jouer
vous avez rencontré monsieur borloo
comment réagit-il que pense-t-il de tout
ça il est évidemment un peu abasourdi de
tout ce qui lui est arrivé il proteste
de son innocence
il continue à le faire est extrêmement
fermement et il a entamé une grève de la
faim il ne s'est pas alimenté depuis
qu'il a été placé sous mandat de dépôt
de dire que dans le dossier il n'y a pas
on ne peut pas parler du fond du dossier
il est interdit de le faire je peux
simplement vous dire qui est la
connaissance il n'y a pas d'élément
déterminant précis matériel objectifs
tangibles qui permettent de retenir une
quelconque culpabilité de monsieur
boulot en ce qui concerne les
accusations portées contre lui
il a fourni des explications qui à mon
sens sont parfaitement satisfaisante je
voudrais ajouter que lorsqu'il a été en
quelque sorte interceptées ou arrêter
mettait le mot entre guillemets par les
personnes qui me
j'y vais il l'a été dans des conditions
également à c'est inadmissible il a été
là ça il a été frappé il a été injuriée
insulté par ces personnes qui au
demeurant sont en ce qui les concerne
des gens certainement parfaitement
honorable or d'autres temps et
certainement très calme je pense que
c'est simplement un indice de
l'excitation et d'énervement sous
l'empiré duquel ils se trouvaient en ce
qui me concerne je pense que peut-être
les premières déclarations aux
accusations qui l'ont portée ne
l'auraient pas été dans d'autres
circonstances et si le chant froid et le
calme vais continuer à habiter ces
personnes une affaire à suivre le reste
de l'actualité en bref monsieur pinel
liste le ministre grec des affaires
étrangères est mort la nuit dernière
d'une crise cardiaque à l'âge de 73 ans
le gouvernement grec l'ue fera demain
des funérailles nationales
un avion cargo antonov 22e qui
transportait des secours pour les
victimes du tremblement de terre du
pérou a disparu au dessus de
l'atlantique nord il y aurait 23
personnes à bord
le prince charles et la princesse anne
d'angleterre sont rentrés hier soir à
londres après trois jours de visite
officielle aux états unis où ils étaient
les invités du président nixon
hier le prince charles a une longue et
sérieuse conversation et cruciaux nixon
dans l'avion qui les ramenait à londres
le prince et la princesse voyageait avec
deux étudiants américains qui veulent
proposer à la délégation nord
vietnamienne de la conférence de paris
d'échanger des étudiants volontaires
contre des soldats américains
prisonniers au nord vietnam
monsieur l'on donne aux ils ont de nous
ancien ministre colombien enlevés il y a
neuf jours a été retrouvé vivant à 150
km de bogota la capitale colombienne la
famille aurait payé une très forte
rançon
la grève des dockers se poursuit en
grande bretagne demain le gouvernement
décidera ou non d'appeler la troupe pour
remplacer les dockers mais les syndicats
menacent de déclencher de nouvelles
grèves
ce n'est pas la famine en grande
bretagne mais pour se ravitailler en
bacon et en neuf nécessaire bien entendu
à tout bon britannique pour son
breakfast plusieurs bateaux font en ce
moment la navette entre l'irlande et
l'ecosse enfin en italie une nouvelle
bagarre hier à reggio di calabre et les
habitants de calabre et de reggio di
calabre protestent contre le choix des
autres villes comme capitale de la
l'arbre hier on a enterré la première
victime de ces manifestations
et après cet enterrement d'autres
manifestations ont suivi
après cinq jours de violences le calme
semblait revenu à reggio de calabre où
avait lieu hier les obsèques de bruno
labat et cet employé de chemin de fer
italiens tués au cours des premières
manifestations de mardi dernier
quatre mille personnes suivaient le
cortège funèbre dont le service d'ordre
était assurée par les cheminots eux
mêmes mais de nouvelles émeutes n'ont
pas tardé à se produire lorsque
plusieurs centaines de manifestants se
sont lancés à l'assaut de la préfecture
la police qui avait enlevé pendant toute
la nuit les barricades dressées au cours
des manifestations précédentes a été un
instant prise au dépourvu les
manifestants qui étaient armés de
pierres et de cocktails molotov et
incendient les voitures tandis que
d'autres en flammes les journaux
partisans de la désignation de catanzaro
comme capitale de la nouvelle région
administrative de calade
car la cause de ces soulèvements
populaires c'est l'instauration des
régions c'est là aussi la source de la
bataille politique qui se déroule au
niveau national et que tente de résoudre
avec beaucoup de difficultés semble-t-il
le président du conseil pressenti
monsieur andreotti vous savez qu'en
france on aime beaucoup célébrer les
centenaires bicentenaire de napoléon
septième centenaire de saint louis etc
louis doucet qui s'est spécialisé dans
les anniversaires injustement oubliée a
découvert qu emilienne d'alençon est né
il ya cent ans
émilienne d'alençon cela ne vous dit
sans doute rien elle était pourtant
l'une des grandes demi mondaine du début
du siècle l'une des grandes des fameuses
années folles qui faisaient des faisait
la politique et les fortunes et puis
emilienne d'alençon est morte oublier
pauvres mais aujourd'hui sa fille se
souvient sa fille qui répond au nom
familier de zouzou le 17 juillet 1870
elle fut déclaré à l'état civil sous le
nom d'émilienne andry mais cette à
emilienne d'alençon belle dévoreuse de
fortune parmi les belles de la belle
époque que le roi léopold ii de belgique
réserver ses faveurs
certains firme d'autre part que sa fille
marthe ressemblerait un peu à edouard 7
pour la première fois qu'elle a joués
elle a débuté avec tahri dans une
tournée et c'est là qu'elle s'est
appelée
sa venue a déclenché ce nom de talent
sens ça va très bien tapé les médias que
face à très faible mais balance dans un
sens parce qu'elle a limité la lnv dès
la fin est très serré la face avant aux
folies bergère en panne et où ou 7 10 mt
a aussi regretté et vous et vous vous
élever des pigeons sur le bord de votre
fenêtre
il faut dire que vous avez des souvenirs
de votre mère j'ai vu dit qu'elle est
absolument vient les six hommes et
rieter on croit même pas un santé ça
pourtant qu'une femme très riche mais
oui naturellement mais la pauvre n'avait
plus rien quand elle est morte à l'homme
et vous aviez laissé des petites photos
ah oui du reste vous voyez comme les
moules et les parcs ou les plaines c'est
que rêvons tenez c'est tout l'héritage
de votre ba oui mais qu'est ce que ça
peut se faire moucher et j'ai pu la
faire revenir figurez vous savez quelle
manière vous êtes moins peu et bien
c'est avec un billet de loterie quand
j'ai gagné quatre cent mille francs en
45 côté les mots et c'est ce qui m'a
permis de la ramener dans notre cas ben
voilà ça ne vous gêne pas de penser que
vous auriez pu avoir une autre vie avec
toute la fortune que votre main je
voulais m'en sers
et au jour là je à quelques pas de l'ex
hôtel particulier de sa mère sur les
champs elysées markt 83 ans marc plus
connu sous le nom de zhu zhu vente des
journaux avenue de wagram
chaque soir après le travail on peut la
voir si on le veut dans son maxime sahel
picorer les miettes de la noire
oui oui avec plaisir la pluie baudoin
nous de ma vie
carmen c'est vous c'est vous dongeois
mais veut nous freiner la ue
si bleu c'est doux c'est vous qui va
freiner faut lire estime aux seuls à
nous la seule que j'aime et que je
toujours jeune femme
et oui et la fin d'une certaine époque
télé midi est terminée je vous remercie
pour votre attention et je vous souhaite
un bon dimanche